hey Jenna and I are gonna go on a hike
and I'm gonna be vlogging with my with
my new GoPro session Jenna's gonna leave
her phone here Oh weird
I don't service yeah but like how are we
gonna take care of the thing some shop
your I know that you have a camera GoPro
Anna phone look you're right so I use
you I've got my water what are we taking
on the other place in the phone here the
water here the GoPro we'll go here nice
oh the big one I thought I had my little
one knife will go next to the phone I'm
so much fun to hike with you chopstick
hold on peg I'll see you guys I'll flip
side cuz I'm taking time for the GoPro
alright peace this is the first time
I've ever used this actually it's cute
I don't really know how to use it yet
there's one single button so when you
press the button you just kind of like
hope for the best so I'm hoping for the
best you know dots prohibited wait it is
not for hibbett antenna says please
clean up after your dogs prohibited up
this way gotcha
the fitness
[Music]
Wow
it's hot out it's hot it's really hot
it's love got to say treasure that might
at it's probably sweaty here this is
probably sweaty so you should be
careless why baby you like to get a
little weight you're holding it the
wrong way
oh my gosh I was yes again you know he's
a girl bro
oh yeah but it's so sweaty I'm sweaty
cat sweaty tattoo sweatiest such as how
you know it's real I know it's real yeah
all right are we done yet
oh we're not even go my god Fitness
fitness Fridays it's Tuesday probably
not going to post this on a Tuesday
though because I'd like to post this
after I do the GoPro unboxing like that
yeah makes sense right you're a boxer
yes well clearly I did in my hand right
oh right back to the tunes real Indic I
go kayo
hung up
heart rate 127 I'm not well
[Music]
this is Brittany 5 we found a nice bench
so we're like cool if a bench is here
you sit on it bench is new it is new and
memory of Lulu and the 13 victims of
Caliban high school for 20 1999 CID line
no where's the time gone like what do
you do if I fell down there what would
you do I say are you okay you say no why
I can't even imagine how awful OD that's
far there's a really good chance you
would not survive well the good news is
what's the good news
perhaps you could like grab oh you
rolled there you will like bounce off of
that and just like yeah Oh given my
track record this week that last week is
like last week it hasn't been seven days
has it it's not been seven days a rough
seven days DJ snake everybody tweet DJ
snake and tell him oh my gosh what
should we tell him ask him if he recalls
not long ago
I don't have nothing to say all right
this one's just hiked I gotta put my
gadgets away so I don't fall and break
my phone I hope I don't break my phone
on this hike like previous ones
every time I've shattered something I
really want to take Libby to Venice do
you think maybe we could do that anyway
that was that was not part of the video
but I guess it is now so this is where
we film Squatch with jenna Marbles
that's a lot what we did that's sad wait
that was like 2 years that was to you
Wow
yes yes yes yeah I love it I same brain
same brain thing we have so many
thoughts I love it this is great ok cool
you guys asked Adele later not the same
thing you are you were thinking I the
hike is over is it that open haha I'm
tired
was exhausting
my heart rate is currently 116 since I
burned 328 calories our elapsed time is
84 minutes that is awful no normal
actually was he moves like an hour and
half really yeah huh how do I stop this
my resting calories 94 total calories
for 23 there you go average heart rate
125 that's not bad
no that's actually that's fine okay cool
well that was fun until next time kids
until left son I'm gonna take those
things away yes
did you dump table no I actually did not
I don't know I'm anyway